خلال السنوات الماضيه شهدت العاصمه باريس
وعدد من المدن الفرنسيه اضرابات عمال جمع
القمامه احتجاجا على قرارات حكوميه مختلفه
في اكتوبر عام 2010 ادى اضراب جميع
القمامه الذي استمر لثلاثه اسابيع على
الاقل الى تراكم النفايات حول ميناء
مارسيليا وكان ذلك بسبب اعلان الحكومه رفع
سن التقاعد الى 62 عاما بدلا من 60 بعدها
بخمس سنوات اضرب اكثر من 45% من عمال جمع
القمامه في باريس عن العمل بحجه ان الاجور
زهيده ولا تتماشى مع تكاليف المعيشه وقبل
ايام من صافره انطلاق بطوله اليورو في
فرنسا في يونيو 2016 بدا اضراب عمال جمع
القمامه بسبب خطه لتخفيف قوانين العمل
ومنح الشركات مساحه اكبر لاتخاذ المزيد من
القرارات بشان التوظيف او الفصل وتحديد
الاجور وفي يناير 2020
وبسبب قانون رفع سن التقاعد الذي يعتزم
البرلمان التصويت بشانه حاليا فاضت
القمامه من صناديق النفايات بعدما اضرب
العمال عن العمل في سته من اصل سبع محارق
نفايات
[موسيقى]